it's 5am in one of germany's biggest
cities and photographer yen's rica is
looking for motifs there's not a soul at
the daily market in Munich the victor a
lien mocked that's rare and that's the
time when rica can pursue his craft
undisturbed in just a few hours the
market will be crowded with people it
was you can you see I'm interested in
well known locations and cities in and
of themselves I'm showing well-known
busy places is free of people the
atmosphere is different then and I can
get a more distinct impression of the
place wouldn't this be the year when I
see the photograph the location devoid
of people then I can perceive it
differently I feel more liberated again
an hour later ricas next stop is a
square just 100 metres away the
marienplatz at 6am there's no trace of
the one and a half million people who
live in the southern german city
he's missing the mints 94 I'd like to
get people of different way to look at
things to teach them a different way to
see me so that they can rediscover
something familiar and I hope they'll
have fun with it yeah I put their spots
Malcolm Kofi's another site the clinic's
plots is a popular evening venue for
concerts and outdoor cinema during the
day it's a place where students meets
and greets at seven in the morning Rika
nearly has it all to himself he took
these pictures of an empties out support
Austria three years ago those works were
published in a 160-page album called
silent space Saltzberg Marquis of
empathy ya know I just like the place
and sauce pork has naturally a certain
type of Barack catchiness that's super
for a photography project because it's
very photogenic twice I've all the other
for the pianist we move on to regensburg
which is about 120 kilometers north of
Munich this is where yinz Lika lives and
works born in castle in 1962 Rica long
worked as a commercial photographer
before he got into the arts for him the
silent space project has allowed him to
live the dream of being an artist many
photographers are fascinated by Mt
cities this here is venice german
photographer Patrick nope took
black-and-white pictures of the Italian
city and published the collection in a
book entitled still is vanna dick silent
Venice
swiss photography rin akong series
invisible cities depicts well-known
buildings in a way that few have seen
before outside of an urban context Rika
says it's all about focusing and
noticing what's important he believes
many people have to learn to see
precisely again he wants to start a
photography school to teach this concept
what you got initially the scenes mom
I'd like to create a Squealer seeing of
course I teach the technical aspect as
well of a faun do you mean but above all
I'd like people to see serenely and
clearly now at a time when we're flooded
with stimulation with the internet and
always being reachable and all that goes
with it quite a bit of awareness somehow
gets lost big yen's Rica will be getting
up early for quite a while yet to
capture images that few people ever get
to see